foreign
sentenced to six and a half years in
prison months after pleading guilty in
her federal fraud case
The Real Housewives of Salt Lake City
Stars heading for a whole new reality at
the sentencing hearing Friday Jen
apologized to her victims admitting my
actions have hurt innocent people
supporting Jen in the courtroom her
husband and two sons she told them I am
profoundly and deeply sorry I'm worried
that like you know as a mom like
basically did I pick my kids up
leading up to her big day in court A
source told E.T Jen was nervous but
relying on her faith and ready to serve
her time and put everything behind her
the only thing I'm guilty of is being
sham amazing it all started nearly two
years ago as cameras rolled on this now
Infamous moment I have some bad news I
got this police and they have handcuffs
out it was so out of left field that we
thought that Jen left the bus and hired
strippers because it was Homeland
Security FBI NYPD and a SWAT team and
Lisa and I were like their outfits don't
even match I know literally we were like
okay who is this what is going on and
the charges conspiracy to commit wire
fraud and money laundering all linked to
a Nationwide telemarketing scheme I'm
not gonna take a plea deal when I'm not
guilty I'm innocent
Jen was later arrested off camera but
the court case had plenty of screen time
in the third season the one thing that
can bring me to tears almost instantly
is thinking of life without my wife by
my side
I know we all broke down and cried we
were upset
quarter math gent pleaded not guilty a
response she turned into a merch line
now Jen says profits from these sales
will be devoted to the victims it wasn't
until July more than a year after her
arrest that Jen took ownership for her
crimes shocking Everyone by reversing
her plea to guilty I honestly thought
that she would fight it to the end I was
shocked I didn't see it coming because
she has said that she's innocent I mean
that's what she's been screaming at the
top of her lungs and as part of Jen's
plea the U.S attorney dropped the money
laundering count if I'm thinking about
my family I can't imagine being away
from them
it would literally kill me after serving
her time Behind Bars Jen begins five
years of supervised release and is
required to pay 9 million dollars to her
victims plus six million dollars in
forfeiture it surprised me
and I was devastated for her needless to
say Jen's confession rocked the Bravo
verse I'm upset and I'm an UPS I'm
especially upset for her victims
I'm upset that she lied for so long I'm
also upset
because frankly you get to know someone
and you get to like them you want to
cheer them on uh and you hate to think
that they're capable of this Behavior I
haven't really thought about my personal
feelings about it she needs more support
now than ever that she's you know facing
this and taking accountability Jen said
to turn herself into custody on February
17th
[Music]
thank you